so for people who don't know man give me
a little bit of your background because
I think a lot of people know you as like
a Philly rapper even though you're not
necessarily from Philly yeah yeah yeah
definitely I'm from Mass if you watch
some of my other interviews and [ __ ] oh
it goes real into like you know I left
Mass you know
part of my criminal life that I had when
I was younger and I ended up in Philly
and that's when you know I went to
prison for a while when I came home
that's when you know I started to push
the music and uh yeah here we are uh how
long were you in prison I like five and
a half that's a serious bid man
some would say uh being like you being a
car so obviously there's like politics
are different in all prisons everywhere
uh California I believe all right it's
definitely different out here yeah I
think like the peckerwoods and the
Southsiders are together and then uh uh
I think blacks and the others and what
is like when you were locked up because
you obviously are a hip-hop artist you
got flavor like do the white stay with
the whites in prison where you were at
like how was like your prison experience
man
I remember when I was my the first
prison I was in was boss I've been in
like six joints the first joint I was in
was was Massachusetts was Worcester
house he was just saying
um
and then what's the hours I remember uh
I remember I was I was 17 getting tried
as an adult so I really didn't have no
business being in there they just they
figured they'd keep me for the last two
months till I turned 18 so they put me I
was in population but I was so young and
so scrawny that nobody bothered me at
all they like I looked like you're a kid
they were like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here I remember showing my papers
to people and being like no look I'm 17
and people would be like yo see how what
the [ __ ] like yo you need anything here
man so they were like looking out for
you it was like that that's how it was
and what's the house where I landed at
that time it wasn't you know whoever had
it under control it was under control it
was all right but I remember two uh two
Irish kids came to myself older guys and
they were like hey bud you got your
paperwork and I was like what the [ __ ]
is that you know I mean they're like all
the paperwork from you getting arrested
and [ __ ] so I was like yeah
he said look you know if you um you know
if you got any problems or anything you
come see us you know I'm saying if like
a black dude or Puerto Rican dude or you
go at it with one of them you don't go
at it with them you just come see us and
we'll go and I wasn't having problems
with no one so I was like all right I
was like looking at him like the [ __ ]
man yeah they're like yeah you're good
look at my paperwork and left so I seen
like that there was some type of order
but you know I didn't really
you know I had so much other [ __ ] going
on I couldn't really focus on it but
like and then I remember like hitting
the Delaware prison
like the joints I was in Delaware like
you weren't allowed to sleep
I'm saying like you couldn't sleep I
seen I see some crazy [ __ ] down there in
Delaware it's nasty down there you could
you could do your time in the prison or
if you're short time you can choose to
go across the parking lot to uh the vop
center you know which is a punishment
Camp so like through being there like
boot camp yo my man they wake you up 4
a.m 5 a.m just reading last names put
your boots on put your boots on so that
would like Excel your sentence so you
get out soon yeah it would like it would
be like if you do a program in the in
the vop center you know it might be like
six months less than your two years or
something so it was worth it but you
weren't allowed to sleep did you do that
you did the vop
yeah but I had to do vop because um
you know I left Massachusetts on the run
and I went to Delaware and I remember I
like served undercover cop and
Massachusetts wouldn't come get me so
Delaware put me on probation and
probation gets me and they're like
they're like all right you're 19. you
never finished high school go back to
high school
um so they put me in the high school up
the street from the house that I was
trapping out of I had my own house so I
was going to school during the day to
appease probation so you were on
probation trapping out of your own crib
at 19. yeah and then at night Friday
nights I had to report to the vop center
and go to prison from Friday to Sunday
and I get out Sunday night and go back
to school Monday morning so every every
weekend they put me on a different pod
because they wouldn't want me to go back
to the same pod and bring it back you
know something bring a bomb in right so
like people would be dying trying to get
me to bring a bomb and like everybody be
trying yo you're a Weekender because
they had to stay they were all doing for
people who don't know what a bomb a bomb
is that's like a balloon yeah whatever
yeah you know that would be something
you put up your ass I don't know about
that you know I mean I'm scared
[Music]
you know what I'm saying I almost got
hemmed up in the situation down there
one time because of that because you had
some money me and a bunch of weekenders
were all in the cell and they put us on
the cell together
they had us all stripping like everybody
take your shirts off and I remember I
like I don't know what happened but I
heard something hit the ground like that
it wasn't you it might have been okay
but I looked down and then and there was
a bag and [ __ ] and I was like and I'm
looking and like no one sees it where
everyone's still getting undressed and
[ __ ] so I kind of step on it and do the
swipe wow notices it and then when
they're cleaning it out they're like yo
hold on what is that and all the other
weekend to start ratting on me right
away they're like this [ __ ] young
prick because they're all you know
they're all yeah you know they had it
with me I'm going in this small like
straight gas taking another living the
life yeah like look at this [ __ ] high
school I'm like a 19 year old junior in
high school Jesus it's like Billy
Madison yeah with the Trapper it was
something crazy so like we kept getting
I kept getting raided and you know there
was nothing to do down there you know
what I'm saying so I was I was hunted
down there in Delaware you know